la beauté physique c'est très aléatoire
d'être mignons parce que quand je suis
dans la rue
les filles viennent me voir et puis
parfois je m'en passerai bien quoi
oui c'est vrai qu'il peut m'arriver de
regarder des garçons dans la rue et sans
aucun complexe parce que tout ce qui est
beau est à regarder et je vois pas
pourquoi on se dissimulerait mais c'est
vraiment que très superficiel et ça n'en
reste pas moins pour la beauté du regard
et on peut être beau à travers à travers
le sourire
ouais ouais le charme le
rire tout ça chirurgie esthétique ça
peut aider certaines personnes à enlever
leur complexe parce que c'est vrai que
des fois c'est
ça gâche une vie mais je sais pas c'est
peut-être un peu dommage
physique c'est pas le plus important et
je trouve que la beauté est plus belle à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
[Musique]